yeah let me see
in8
you all right hey I want to welcome
everybody very much U and you know one
of the things I like to do is I like to
do the pledge so representative would
you mind leading us in a pledge and
we're going to
startg to the plag of the United States
of America to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liy andice for all so welcome to
the subcommittee on Alzheimer's disease
and other related dementia thank you
everybody for showing up we appreciate
it and I think uh first of all we'll
we'll start with a roll call and um
we'll start from our
right and and if you wouldn't mind
putting on your mic just press your
little red button yeah that didn't work
there you go here
we would you like me to do that again uh
Maria cango from Silverthorn a Delta day
Center waren MTA the Board of
Nursing J Gupta from uh Harbor homes in
Nani
Hamshire Jessica esin with the
Alzheimer's
Association Senator Kevin aard District
12 representative Eric Alon Derry
Rockingham 13 I think no
hi Wendy Alman Department of Health and
Human
Services hi Kathy Harvard I'm from
Hanover I'm a caregiver and U work
closely with the Alzheimers Association
as a
volunteer I'm Janessa Luke I'm a
director of social services at Bedford
Nursing and Rehab Center all right just
for all our comfort we can do this watch
this just like that and then we uh there
you
go okay and your own personal microphone
so ladies and gentlemen so uh welcome to
the committee and uh we appreciate you
all being here we know that uh uh this
hasn't been going on for a while so we
wanted to reestablish it and so uh I
think our first order of business is uh
we did the roll call member
introductions um we need a clerk does
anybody want to be a
clerk I'm happy to
be so all in favor of Jessica becoming
our clerk I any oppose seeing none
welcome and thank you for uh
volunteering AB for being part of uh
that um and as our Clerk and seeing how
you know um a lot about this particular
topic uh would you mind giving us uh
basically a little history of the
subcommittee and any kind of updates
that you feel are relevant yeah
absolutely thank you so um as the
senator said this uh subcommittee was
established legislatively in
2014 um and met for a while stopping in
about 2018 there was some staff turnover
in my role and for various reasons
meetings sort of dropped off um I've
been with the association a little over
a year now and really prioritized
reconstituting this I think uh given our
rapidly aging population the anticipated
23% increase in instances of Alzheimer's
and Dementia in the next two years in
New Hampshire this was really something
that merited doing a deep dive on and
having a subcommittee be meeting on so
uh that's why we're here today in the
packets in front of you I included sort
of a master dock just providing the
establishing legislation some of the
history of the subcommittee um the
statutory charge which is listed under
membership and scope of work um and then
the some previous subcommittee activity
legislation that the subcommittee had
spearheaded in the past which um was
really important and has proven very
successful in the state so I just wanted
to provide that background and context
and really thank all of you for your
willingness to serve on this
reconstituted committee I think it's
it's really timely and important and I
look forward to the work we'll
do thank you very much and uh basically
the scope of our discussion per
statute yeah so the scope um again it's
in that document under membership and
scope of work uh it includes reviewing
other states plans for Alzheimer's
disease um every state has an
Alzheimer's plan ours was last updated
by the subcommittee in 2015 um so is
certainly out of date and is something
I'd like to prioritize updating uh
survey individuals with Alzheimer's to
more accurately estimate the number of
people with this in the state study
existing services and resources
including but not limited to type cost
and availability of dementia Services
dementia specific training requirements
for long-term care staff quality
measures in care settings
capacity of Public Safety and law
enforcement to respond to people with
Alzheimer's disease availability of home
and community-based resources for folks
with Alzheimer's and respit care to uh
assist families and
caregivers inventory of long-term care
dementia care units and beds adequacy
and appropriateness of geriatric psych
psychiatric units for folks with
behavioral disorders associated with
Alzheimer's and Dementia Assisted Living
Residential options for people people
with dementia State support for
Alzheimer's disease research through New
Hampshire universities and other
resources determin State policies and
responses necessary to provide clear and
coordinated services and supports to
persons families and caregivers living
with Alzheimer's and develop strategies
to identify and address any gaps in
service and um as I mentioned establish
a New Hampshire state plan for alimer
and other related dementia as approved
by HHS oversight which of course we are
a subcommittee of
um and in your packet I did include the
last um the most recent updated report
again from 2015 that the subcommittee
had done at that
time thank you thank you thank you so
you know I was talking to Jessica
earlier um just offline and uh you know
just just this previous election you
know I'm walking down the street with my
dog you know and
uh I ran into a neighbor and my neighbor
said hey you're you're Senator AAR
hey yeah uh and we got a little bit of
conversation and his wife was standing
right next to him and he said uh we were
just talking he says by the way my has
to men
you and I was just kind of floored by
that I really was floored by that
because you know we saw her crying in
the in the yard this summer and we we
thought nothing of it well she was just
picking up some weeds and was just
crying and apparently she's she has
a advanced stage of it another friend of
mine uh he's about 85 years old he was
just diagnosed with
uh um early you know stages of it so
it's you know I I know a few people I've
I clean for a living and so I've walk
into people's homes and oh by the way my
mother or or by the way and I think one
of the common themes that uh a lot of
people are are are struggling with is
the fact
that it it's almost like a you're by
yourself right it's like some people
like to talk about it some people don't
like to talk about it most people don't
uh years ago if you had a special needs
individual you know they were kind of
like hidden away back back then until
people found out that there were
resources and I think the same kind of
spirit goes on with
dementia uh it's a private thing you
know and uh and and that being said what
happens is people suffer in silence you
know and I think one of the one of the
things that we we can do with this
committee is definitely make awareness
what are the resources and what how can
people find these resources and I think
that's the important part I hate
committees that don't do anything that
just come and meet I want to come up
with some solutions and something that
you know we can legislate or we can uh
we can help facilitate uh some remedies
uh to help our population and like
Jessica said you know got a 23% increase
in in the in dementia across the
state uh and I I hear that New Hampshire
is one of the the most aging states in
the union so that being said we got to
work cut out for us as far as making
resources and and I think part of making
that known is is our our elected
officials really they get busy you know
and they hear sound bites just like
everybody else so our our job will be to
you know uh make a make them aware I
think in in ways that they can have a
plan of action that's one of the things
I always look for is uh everybody in
this room is like hicc of a lot smarter
than me all I know is how to connect the
dots you know they put a pretty face and
that's what I am just kidding just
kidding uh but I I think uh one of the
things I really would like to see our
our ways of to be being effective other
than just being a committee so and and
everybody's welcome to to add to that
um enough enough about that but now if I
could just get a little bit of
background a little bit everybody
introduce themselves a little bit but
can I start with you a little bit what's
your
story what's my story well I started off
as a kindergarten director and ended up
as the Director of an adult day Center
where people have
dementia um but there's quite a story
going on right now I don't know if
you've heard but three of the adult day
centers in Southern New Hampshire are
closing as of November 30th so I have
been been spending my last week or so um
answering phones that are ringing off
the hook um trying to place the people
um it was senior class in Hamstead which
is the closest one to me I'm in
Salem um so we're trying to fit um all
of the people from that program into our
program and I maxed out as of this
morning so I'm starting a waiting list
um most of the people that were in my
program so I was averaging about 15 a
day coming back from covid and my
numbers didn't really get up to pre-co
numbers as of yep but they are they've
surpassed that now um but we uh most of
the people that we had in our program
had dementia I had a couple people there
for physical reasons primarily but
almost everybody had dementia um the
population that I'm getting from from
Hamstead uh they're a little bit younger
um and not everybody has dementia
they're they're there for physical
reasons um so it's going to
be it'll be day today we're going to
figure this out and um but there was an
article in I think it was the union
leader last I think it was the union
leader um and they quoted a woman from
one of the other places at close saying
that um she couldn't find a place to
that took Medicaid um we
do um no so Medicare and this is my pet
peeve Medicare does not cover adult day
they'll they'll pay to go to a nursing
home when the time so all of our people
have to be nursing home eligible to get
into the program so all the people that
come to my program are eligible eligible
to be in a nursing home and if they run
out of money Medicare will kick in and
pay for that but they don't pay for
adult a so the only people that can
afford it
because um we were at 95 a day and and
we're a nonprofit and that's still not
breaking even at the numbers that I have
at at 30 people a day I'll I'll break
even I I think um I hope but without
raising the rates too much um but it's
$100 a day so my new we have a new
administrator says well we're we're the
only game in town why don't we raise the
race a little bit I said because these
are people with all sign is and if
they're coming five days a week they're
already paying $2,000 a month out of
their pocket that's a lot of
money um so it's
expensive it's expensive to run an adult
a good Adult Day program it's expensive
to R run a lousy Adult Day program um
they're just expensive to run um and
um right now we're we're in bind so the
the people that run those programs say
there's still Easter sales in Manchester
um which is another big program and
there's one out in the Sea Coast there's
one up north um but we're kind of in a
crisis at the moment so that needs to be
uh discussed obviously wow yeah morine
it's Moren right yes Moren I I I said
what's your story because I I couldn't I
forgot your name and I couldn't read it
from
here
thank I apologize Mar that's okay
um I'm weing where talk from um I was
appointed to the board of nursing been
on there for a couple of years now um I
also I teach Len AIDS and I've been
teaching Len a since
2010 and I have watched the program go
from 60 out well my first class that I
taught lnas the theory was 100 hours
plus the 60 hours we're down to 40
hours is what the state says because
we've gone with the federal instead of
what the state has always said and I'm
watching them cut corners and I've seen
them corners
on dementia care and I would love to
have a whole
section just a whole section on dementia
care
that they're not there's no no way you
can do this whole thing in 40 hours of
theory you can't you can't do it so we
do have and we have started we got a
grant
last last year and it's taken us quite a
while it's a program between Dober Adult
Learning Center and Dober High School
CTC and we started this program it's for
lnas and it's for um
English as a second language is the
majority of our
students that have had health care in
other countries that have come forward
here with their
background and I thought we were GNA I
thought it was going to be more of a
challenge than it is it's a fabulous
program I thought I was going to be
pulling my hair out of my head I love
it um the back ground that so many of
these people have we have so many people
from other countries in this state that
have background in healthare and we need
to get
them that's
my the main
council do I call you doctor no I can
play one on TV if you
want you need a white cook for that well
I'm just a drug dealer from City of
Nashua um so couple of my family members
have been struggling with
Alzheimer's um but as a pharmacist I
know we have not really succeeded in
conquering this disease we have less
than turn drugs um not very effective
just symptomatic relief
mostly uh what I really am passionate
about personally is non-pharmacological
interventions I've been teaching yoga in
mindfulness I've traveled and talked in
more than 40 States I do CN events just
teaching Healthcare Providers how to
deprescribe
medications um I also believe in
healthcare we fail we are notorious in
failing
consistently uh in finding out what is
the root cause of the problem and we
don't fix the root
cause if somebody has strapped throat
and they have fever we don't just give
them tyol we also give them antibiotic
but when it comes to dementia
hypertension diabetes everything we just
treating the symptom like treating the
fever but without giving fixing the root
cause so just this morning I was reading
from CNN that ppis the proton pump
inhibitors available over the counters
people are definitely overusing that
category of medications has 33% more
possibility of causing
dementia so different mechanism of
action so really we this is what I am
passionate about figuring out what is
causing the root CA what is the root
cause of the problem and fixing that um
medications of course that's my bread
and butter literally I make money by
selling drugs but deprescribing is
something which we really need to focus
on you said Des subscribing
deprescribing prescribing yes so that's
what I teach in medical schools in
nursing programs and uh Pharmacy of
course um yeah thank you thank you we
already heard from
you
Jess esland I'm the senior public policy
manager with the Alzheimer's Association
been here a little over a year um and
I'll just say that anecdotally in the
time short time I've been at the
association I have yet to meet someone
and share with what I do um that hasn't
been touched in some way by this disease
I was telling the senator that so um
thrilled to to be here and learn and
work with you all and and see what we
come up with super representative um
thank you very much my name is Erica
Leon I'm a representative from dairy and
I um volunteered to join this because I
thought we'd have a significant amount
of time with my father-in-law dealing
with finally getting him diagnosed with
Alzheimer's um he ended up uh passing
this past September but the experience
watching his resistance to any sort of
diagnosis of dementia Alzheimer the
resistance to planning the resistance to
doing anything that would acknowledge
that he had this disease that was going
to progress was a serious Challenge and
his family members we'd have we had we
dealt with the experience of not having
any of those sort of surrounds where
there might be some way to notify the
local police that I believe he has
dementia he hasn't been diagnosed we're
doing as much as we can to provide for
him but he doesn't want to accept it
because he has dementia and to figure
out how we can build more of those
supports so those people who want to
help but by respecting their autonomy
and the fact that they're able to make
those decisions they it's their right to
refuse that help but to make sure that
when that time comes for help they're
ready and um also just looking at that
whole process of trying to destigmatize
it because it is common so many people
deal with this you know we don't
stigmatize uh we don't stigmatize we
actually stigmatize way too many
diseases actually I was going to say
high blood pressure and diabetes but no
people point to what you're eating even
though that's not always the root cause
um but to figure out some way that we
can do that and even my pipe dream would
be to figure out some way to have some
sort of transition plan not where
somebody could voluntarily go from
managing all their finances to putting
into place a voluntary shift of
responsibilities as their condition
progresses so that while they're able to
talk about what they want and when they
would want to have help you know there's
some sort of a contractual process that
they could enter into with their family
members and their caregivers and figure
out how to have that oversight and you
know not something anybody would be
forced into but at least if we had a
pathway that you could choose to
participate in I think it would help
smooth that pathway and after discussing
this in the community there's so many
people in in Derry that have reached out
to me and surrounding areas trying to
get their family members trying to get
their neighbors you know I just had one
of the teachers of my kids Co-op say
they had a neighbor who they're trying
to figure out where to place them
because she's walked out of the house
too many times and they're worried if
she does that in Winter they'll lose her
you know it's it's it's an issue where
we need to figure out how to address it
and you know I'm I'm not here for the
easy solutions because those things have
already been done I'm here to work to
get to the hard solutions for the things
we need to do thank you representative
Wendy hi um Everybody um again Wendy
Alman I'm the bureau chief for the
Bureau of elderly and adult services
within the Department of Health and
Human Services um I guess I'll touch on
P from a personal perspective I have had
um many experien is right from high
school going to LNA school or CNA school
back then um you know 25 30 years a well
probably 30 years ago
now and uh so I've worked in the field
I've worked in home care um I've worked
in direct care as well as day rehab for
people with disabilities in um nursing
home settings um and then uh started
working with the Department of Health
and Human Services where I transitioned
more to a
policy um program uh role um and have
been with the department for 25 years
now um in various roles uh one of those
uh being the administrator for our aging
and disability Resource
Centers where we've built that program
um to align with uh Federal initiatives
and uh program prams for older American
Zach services for caregiver support um
and uh funding that we receive from the
state for Alzheimer's disease and
related dementias to provide education
support and uh respit um to family
caregivers um who want to uh receive
respit or need supplemental help um and
education and support from their peers
um and we've also
uh built uh and oversee programs within
the bureau such as the choices for
Independence Medicaid waiver program and
uh older American act services that
support um Adult Day Home Care Services
hom delivered meals um and our Adult
Protective Services so um over the years
many experiences many um lenses to um
the work related to Alzheimer's disease
and related dementias and we've
currently um built into our uh state
plan on Aging that's renewed every four
years goals and objectives and
strategies related to um Alzheimer's
disease related dementia public
awareness um agef friendly
language um many things that we hope
that will you support
and build capacity for our service
system um to uh help this population and
their caregivers and providers in terms
of awareness and training so so is there
any legislation as a byproduct of what
you just said that you that's that's on
that's in the works right now um I don't
think there's any current legislation
being filed we at the department we're
currently um reviewing some of the
things that come our way in legislative
requests um and I I haven't seen
anything um to date yet but in the last
year's uh session we did have have a
bill um that uh legislated and funded a
public awareness campaign campaign for
off that was a really good bill
so that was a very good B that was a
very good thank you very much thank you
hi um so I'm Kathy Harvard and I'm here
in the capacity of uh as someone who was
a caregiver for many years for my
husband who passed from younger onset
Alzheimer's a few years ago but I
accompanied and my young children we
accompanied my husband on his more than
decad long journey through dementia and
in that process navigated the world of
Elder Support Services the health system
and um at that point we were a younger
age I I was able to find out at an
earlier time exactly what worked and
what didn't work and um so I I have been
involved since that time um doing what I
can on advocacy and policy and awareness
raising on behalf of the families who
are dealing with this and so you've
already touched on so many of it let's
just start with stigma and let's talk
about
awareness most of the caregivers that I
am familiar with will tell you that they
some of it
self-stigmatizing we have to change
attitudes and attitudes can be changed
by leaders and we're better then right
here so starting by creating a different
kind of
conversation about dementia of All Sorts
not just Alzheimer's and exactly what
you alluded to we used to talk about 50
years ago cancer was the c-word right
we've changed the way we handle all
kinds of disabilities this one has got
to be changed just by the sheer numbers
that we are dealing with so using keying
into public awareness campaigns which
don't cost a whole lot of money but have
huge amount of impact in liberating
families to be able to talk more openly
and as we found out now is that in fact
there may be a way to to reduce by risk
prevention to reduce the incidence of
Dementia by certain brain health
messages that are older population needs
but we if they won't listen and they
won't self-identify to their doctors and
the doctors are not pushing then we are
missing opportunities that are costing
us all a lot of money so I feel that
there's both a public awareness side of
things and I personally have been able
to participate on a number of policy and
legislative changes here um over the
years that had a direct impact on me and
so I know that that singling out the
those two or three pieces we can do
every year they will have impact on
families they will make a difference
they will either save money or they will
save sorrow but they will help and so I
think identifying what priorities we can
make progress on is would be huge so
thank you the entire system needs to be
navigated more openly and whatever way
that we can do that legislatively or
through public awareness it's it's a
very very pressing need thank you
so I am um Janessa Luke I'm the director
of social services at Bedford Nursing
and Rehab Center um I started Healthcare
in 2010 I was a dietary aid and an
assisted living in Massachusetts um
worked my way up and was a Bo and
director of admissions for many many
years um something that happened to me
personally I lost my fiance in 2019 to
Suicide um so at that point I had an
opportunity
a little bit after to take over Social
Services in my building um and not only
with my own healing did that help me
with helping others um I just also have
seen such a need for the resources that
people need in the community um just the
support the awareness kind of what
everyone has said so you know I'm here
to help want to make a change well we
appreciate you being here thank you
yeah
so I think one of the things that I'd
like to see is um if
um instead of having a book if you can
give me some bullet points as to what
you would like to see out of this
committee um not a long letter just
bullet points I want to see some
progress on this bullet point or this
bullet point or this bullet point
whether it's the decription or we have
an issue with uh we got some closing and
that that's going to put a really big
burden so if I can get a list from
everybody as to what they want to
accomplish uh through this committee it
would be helpful for us and then we can
narrow in zero in on on some quick
Solutions
um I I'm sure we can go on and on and on
I I think one of the things that I I'd
also like to consider is the living
conditions of some of these individuals
why would I say
that um some of you know that I I am a
cleaner I've I've been cleaning since 15
years
old and uh years ago I used to do uh I
used to do a lot of cleaning up here in
the conquered area and years back before
any of your times I think being there
were uh there were some needs up here
right across the way over here and there
was a gentleman he had
Alzheimer's and uh they came up and said
would you mind cleaning his
house the swill that people live in
that are abandoned is breathtaking
literally and uh I remember going in
there and I said okay I just SW him out
of the house for a few hours cleaned out
the entire house and they
said you can keep whatever you
find uh well when you see the swill that
these people live in you think well I
wouldn't want anything and I uh I
cleaned the house went into the the
apartment opened up
uh the kitchen the cabin there was
garbage stacked all the way to the
top at the bottom of that that
garbage was a violin now some of you
know I like
instruments so I cleaned everything out
I found the violin and I opened it
up I looked inside the thing the the
violin case and the bridge was broken
but wasn't super bad wow this is cool
maybe I'll I'll keep this I looked in
inside and it said
Stratovarius I closed it I put it under
his bed I clean that apartment and she
brought him back and he he was okay to
live in this clean Environ I went under
the bed I took the
Stratovarius and I put it on his bed and
I I said I'm want to show you something
did did you know you have
this no
expression yep
come to find out he was a World War II
vet I found all his medals and secret
missions that he did and I I displayed
him on his on his on his cabinet and on
his
bureau and
um I walked out of there and I wouldn't
take that I would I wouldn't take the
violin it was just too
valuable um but I left there
thinking he's left alone he served this
country
somebody had pity on him to clean this
place but his family abandoned him let
the state take care of
it and he lived in
swill and I'm going to tell you there
are more people like that than people
realize living in the state because I
cleaned a lot of
them and most people wouldn't walk into
some of these
conditions but after a while you know
that to me it's heartless where's the
family where are the resources for this
individual um and as precious as that
violin was stacked under that garbage
there was
something multiple times more valuable
and it was that soul that lived in that
swill and uh I would like to make sure
that we can at least consider you know
also some of the living conditions and
resources for individuals that you'd be
surprised surpris what you get used to
you be surpris I'm I'm sure you you've
seen it I'm sure you've seen it some of
you but that I definitely want that into
consideration um because it's it's
subhuman and some of some of the things
that these people live in but with that
I would definitely like to see some
bullet points I'd like to see some
solutions uh some plans of
actions and if there are amendments that
we can attach to any piece of
legislation that would solve a certain
crisis let us know I mean let me know
because we're past the gauntlet now as
far as uh legislative putting in things
but I am the chair of
WS so I don't but we can also always
attach an amendment to something um if
if necessary so uh with that being said
um that's your homework if that's okay
and I guess uh our our we're coming into
the holiday season so I think one of the
things is scheduled the next meeting um
and if you have some things that we can
bring present to the next meeting that'd
be great we can do one more before the
end of the year let's uh agree on a date
at some point um if if you're all in
favor do we know sir do we know how many
how often we're going to meet every
other week every other week I'm kidding
I'm oh no I thought that was exciting
I'm
so no that's supposed to make your heart
drop no I I think you are you have a
room full of people that are really
motivated yeah and and uh I really want
to take advantage of that and by the way
I want to recognize Tom prol for being
in the in the audience as well who's uh
one of the people that uh helped me
draft the legislation that uh that was
mentioned earlier and Tom and Jessica
also but um
welcome not really but go ahead yes you
can of course
yes thank you for the record Tom prol
from Demmer and prol I've represented
the Alzheimer's Association for the
better part of the last decade and was
here with the infancy and the foundation
of this permanent subcommittee so um and
I just want to say over the years this
working group has put together a lot of
great uh IDE ideas that have become laws
including you know creating the silver
alert program for when someone goes
missing um we have worked to for
training required uh hours of training
um in regards to specific Alzheimer's
and Dementia which would has really
helped with I think uh the retention of
those workers because they're not
burning out when they learn when they
given the tools to properly handle
situations uh we worked on uh Lang
anguage to change the definition of
Alzheimer's disease to create more
eligibility for the resit grant and I
just want to say um sitting back here
and listening to all of you I'm really
excited because I think this group can
do a lot of great work um so I'm just
really looking forward to seeing what
you all put out there but that's all I
have to say I was just itching to say it
yeah we appreciate that and uh if you uh
see anything uh in in in the works in in
the pipeline that we can attach
something to or uh you know that'd be
great and if there's some grants that we
can use for for
Education the big concern right now I
think is the closing of some facilities
I think that's one of the things that we
really got to thank you Tom uh we got to
really focus on so
um let's uh let's come up with some
bullet points as a plan of action and I
think uh other than that what we just
our
next big thing to do is come up with
another date to meet and we we should
have all that in in uh in advance
yet I add um to that problem
Transportation oh yeah yeah yeah just I
second that yeah yeah put it in the you
know in in the bullet points of things
for us to to look at and if there are
some resources that we have not tapped
into put that in there as well um if
there uh are any rules that are uh
hindering because things in rules can
have uh you know let me know and let
let's see if we can't um make a law to
change a rule because that's how we do
it right actually I'm on J car we can
always ask to have a rule changed and
then if it's if it's appropriate then
they can bring it through the ru making
process if they don't change it on their
own then we can pass a law in order to
encourage them much more strongly
exactly so that being said uh I don't
know if we're able to come up with a
date now or Senator if it's helpful I'm
happy to connect with Trisha and I'll
I'll send out another um availability
poll if that works for folks working
with her on your calendar that works
yeah okay great I'll do that today she's
the brains of my operation that's for
sure uh so with that I don't know if
there's anything else we need to do
right other than scheduling a meeting
and uh yeah definitely come up with
something and I promise you if it's a
book I won't read it I I just won't I I
just and I think that's one of the
things a lot of senators do if they see
even the longest of emails um unless
they are extremely barded which they're
not uh so bullet points are usually the
best way to get things done with a plan
of action and uh it's like cutting to
the chase nobody wants to Hero you know
just just get it done that's kind of how
I'm I'm I'm designed I'm wired so um any
final Thoughts with every anybody
anybody want to add anything to
anything with that is there a motion to
a journ so moved is there second All In
of adjournment thank you all right any
oppose see none thank you very much and
and those uh name tags that didn't show
up we can keep them included to right
into the conversation yes yep yep all
right thank you all thank you and Happy
Thanksgiving if I don't see
you I don't think we'll be back before
then well you never know you never
[Laughter]
know
that